this government has acted urgently and  decisively on the side of hard-working  families and businesses  we reversed the National Insurance  increase we helped millions of  households with their energy bills and  help thousands of businesses avoid  bankruptcy  we are taking back our energy  Independence so we are never again  beholden to Global Market fluctuations  or malign foreign powers  from my time as prime minister I am more  convinced than ever that we need to be  bold and confront the challenges that we  face  as the Roman philosopher Seneca wrote  it's not because things are difficult  that we do not dare it's because we do  not dare that they are difficult  we simply cannot afford to be a  low-growth country where the government  takes up an increasing share of our  national wealth